man i'm so hyped for this under the red
hood sequel
again not my proudest whoa hey how you
doing
so as always it's been a big week for dc
news
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the new look at the
snyder cut steppenwolf
debunking the batman mountain dew ads a
fake catwoman scene and talking about
leaks on the new suicide squad game
because of this there will be some
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined about the upcoming
titles
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now don't forget we do videos like
this every week
so if you still unsubscribe then make
sure you do as
we have a right laugh over here and try
and bring you the stories without the
click bait
now with all that out the way this is
the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka batman's
biggest bat fan
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
as always
zack snyder's vero account is full of
behind the scenes looks at his projects
and upcoming movies i still have no idea
what vero really is not really used it
and i don't even know if anyone else is
on there but occasionally
i stopped by to see what's going on in
the snyder verse
now on the 8th of august which just so
happens to be my birthday
snyder gave me the greatest gift of all
by dropping a look at a production still
of steppenwolf
as we can see from it the character is
back to his original design
that's more in line with his look in
batman v superman
though the cgi on him isn't finished to
me it still looks way better than how he
was in the justice cut
this is going to be the scene that takes
place in the gotham harbor
and originally when snyder showed this
moment to the press all the way back in
2016
they said it was one of the best action
scenes in a dc movie ever i still don't
know how much it will change from what
we eventually got
but just knowing that steppenwolf will
be here looking like some rabid animal
that's about to rip everyone's head off
i think will add a lot more to what's
going on
snyder said that this image was low res
and that in full
high definition he'll look a lot more
menacing and intimidating
this is something that fans of the film
are excited for and after the theatrical
version look like the michelin man after
hitting the gym
anything feels like an improvement on
that now a notable thing to take from
this image
is that the initials zs appear on it
this could be taken
one of two ways and though it could
easily mean zack snyder
it could potentially be taken as zoic
studios who are rumored to be working on
the vfx for the piece
i also think there's a timestamp of one
hour and one minute
and the scene in the theatrical cut
takes place around the 55 minute mark
so we know we will have probably had at
least five minutes of additional footage
at this point
there's also the fact that snyder is
cutting out the rooftop scene from the
beginning of the movie
and also the music number which i
actually like so there's probably gonna
be about 12 minutes of footage at this
point
which will be different to what we saw
in cinemas i think i'm kind of getting
obsessive at this point just breaking
all these stupid little details down
but speaking of obsessive we've also
broken down the fake
batman mountain dew advert that's been
floating around to show where the
original images come from
now you might have seen these out and
about and it's actually been picked up
by a lot of big sites like comicbook.com
this is because apparently it has the
first like a catwoman silhouette
and also the riddler unfortunately it's
fake
and i was actually talking to chris
parker from 3c films about it
and he said he'd pretty much made a
video and had it ready to go live
before it was being announced as fan
made still though
sites ended up running with it and chris
even got quoted on comicbook.com as a
source
even though it wasn't real haha got him
that'll teach you for making better
batman videos of me a guy
at the end you might have more views but
i got you now it completely blew up and
it's kind of crazy to me as it was
actually debunked
fairly early on after being released i
think with it being a slow news here
places just ran with it because it's
easier to report on a lie
get the clicks and then announce it as
fake later and also get the clicks for
that
now the first part of the ad which is
meant to be a look at batman
actually comes from wizard magazine and
it's been recolorized to make it look
more in line with the branding of
mountain dew
delicious delicious mountain dew
available
now next up is the catwoman silhouette
which was being used as a first look at
the catsuit
this was taken from a promo image for
arkham city
and last is the riddler who is actually
just some artwork for hugo strange
that had its colors changed and just a
mask added over the top of it
as always shout outs the bat source and
mr batfleck on twitter for getting to
the bottom of this
and discovering where the original
images came from and
shame on all the people who reported on
it being real even though they knew it
was fake
i'm gonna get you in addition to this i
also got sent an apparent leak of a
scene
which showed that catwoman was the
daughter of the liar in case you don't
know
there was a leaked scene a couple of
months ago that had a guy in a chair
with a bag over his head
and then the bag was written liar this
also started making the rounds on the
internet
but it's even crazy to me that this
picked up almost as much attention as
the mountain dew ad
firstly the image of zoe is taken from
fantastic beasts
secondly the writing daughter of liar
looks like it was done
with a spray paint can on microsoft
paint
and lastly if sofia lillis was in the
movie
it just would have picked up so much
attention at this point and thus yes
this image is completely fake so sorry
to disappoint everyone
but we really do try and go through this
stuff with a fine-tooth comb to make
sure that what we're reporting is legit
i've never seen a film like this where
there's so many bits of fake information
flying about
and hopefully this has ruined your day i
mean
made you a bit more skeptical about
things in the future
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the mcu
infinity saga box set to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to begin with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the stories
in the comment section below the winner
is going to be chosen at random on the
15th of august and the cell will be
shipped out from then to over gets the
prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
and lastly are some leaks on the
upcoming rocksteady suicide squad game
in case you don't know we actually
reported on this last month
and the game was pretty much confirmed
by domains that warner brothers
registered
this included suicidesquadgame.com and
suicide squad killerjusticeleague.com
in addition to this the same source has
recently posted some brand new
information on the upcoming title
now why this seems like it could be
legit it's because the post was removed
but thanks to nerd stash we do know what
was in it we have pretty much been
hammering home for the last five minutes
that all leaks like this should be taken
with a pinch of salt
so do the same with these as we won't
know for definite until we play the game
so according to the leak the game will
be available on ps5
xbox series x and pc with a launch
window of late 2021 to early 2022
the leak has said that the game will
take place in the batman arkham universe
which makes a lot of sense since rock
steady built it
and are now creating this new title the
story will apparently center on amanda
walla
and lex luthor attempting to create
doomsday through project cadmus
in order to eliminate the justice league
wallah plans to capture the justice
league by sending in the suicide squad
and bringing them in alive in order to
await their doomsday
puns puns puns now you will play as
certain members of the squad
including harley quinn who'll be
equipped with a fast moving bat
and powerful hammer for melee or dual
pistols and a submachine gun for
wrenched attacks
there's also deadshot who can use his
wrist mounted guns
and an assault rifle next is death
stroke
who plays like batman in the arkham
games and in addition to this
other playable characters are cheetah
king shark captain boomerang count
vertigo
and enchantress meanwhile the justice
league roster is made up of batman
superman wonder woman flash green latin
martian manhunter shazam and hawk girl
the leakers said that they managed to
play against two of the bosses
and that these were wonder woman and
batman they said that batman pretty much
plays exactly like how he did in the
arkham games
predominantly using gadgets and stealth
attacks
the users stated that there was even a
predator section similar to the arkham
series
however the game developers had switched
things up a bit
and you were actually the prey this time
whereas batman was the one hunting you
when discussing wonder woman they said
that she uses her lasso a lot to try and
grab you
and then she pulls you in with a sword
she's also able to block a lot of the
standard attacks with a shield
so you have to combat her in order to
break her defenses
and take it down to me this sounds like
one of the big boss battles in the last
of us part 2
that i don't want to spoil in case you
haven't played it but after hearing all
this info
i'm very excited to see what could be
happening with the game it feels like
it's been forever since the last rock
steady title
and i know that arkham vr was one
technically but yeah
it's been far too long i do hope that we
also get to play as the justice league 2
at one point
because that's a big thing that people
including myself
have been crying out for for years now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on all these leaks
and if you believe them or if you don't
if you've heard anything else about any
of the titles mentioned in this video
then make sure you drop them in the
comments section below
as we'd love to discuss them with you if
you enjoy this video and want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out a video on the rumored catwoman hbo
mac show which is going to be linked at
the end
we go over all the details we have so
far so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
if you want to come chat who's after the
show either follow us at heavyspoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with the channel and hopefully we
see you soon
but if not thanks for making it until
the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you